So the original star wars trilogy
episodes four,
five,
and six has a total run time of six
hours and 20 minutes.
Each movie is pretty much the same
length,
a little over two hours,
and they're also the same in another
respect.
The amount of time that they feature the
series main villain.
Darth vader in terms of actual
screentime vader,
gets astonishingly little in a new hope.
He's in the film for only eight minutes
in empire strikes back.
He's in it for 12 minutes and in return
of the Jedi,
he tops out at about 14 minutes on
screen,
but these altogether and darth vader
maybe cinemas most iconic villain,
if not character in general,
flashed across movie screens for a total
of only 34 minutes.
In this video,
I want to take a look at vader's visual
footprint in the original trilogy to see
if we can't locate what gives him this
iconic status in such a short time.
In episode four,
Darth Vader is only in six percent of
the movie and his scenes are striking in
how the character fades into the
background both narratively and
visually.
For the bulk of episode four or Vader is
portrayed as the subordinate of grandma
off Tarkin,
so a good portion of his screen time has
him in the background or off to the
side,
cut off,
sometimes out of focus even when he's
being filmed directly.
Vader's black uniform feeds into the
shadows of the set and there is a
noticeable lack of separation between
foreground and background.
Now it's hard to say how much of this is
a narrative or thematic choice and how
much is down to the constraints of
filming all of Darth vader scenes in
episode four with the exception of the
first take place in or around the
deathstar Gilbert Taylor,
the cinematographer,
was famously annoyed with filming these
scenes because he didn't like the black
and gray sets made by John Barry,
which provided little opportunity for
targeted lighting.
Taylor was actually forced to cut holes
in the sets and outfit them with courts
lamps that lit the environment evenly
for flexibility in shooting flexibility
but not specificity.
This is not to say that darth vader
doesn't make an impact in episode four.
I mean,
this is the film that launched the whole
thing,
and visually the movie does make a bold
statement out of the gate by introducing
vader right away as a menacing jet black
presidents against the white interior
walls of a rebel spaceship,
but I do think that there's more iconic
vader imagery to come.
You see that right away.
In episode five,
the Empire strikes back the first time
vader appears on screen.
You get this iconic helmet shot from
behind.
What's so cool about this shot is that
it's essentially black on black and yet
director Irvin Kershner and
cinematographer Peter [inaudible],
find a way to make vader stand out with
reflections and texture and shape all
throughout the film.
They find ways to key into the elemental
quality of Vader as an archetype or
representation of evil,
and they upped the ante on the work
done.
And episode four in that movie,
vader's helmet,
for example,
is dirty smudged used.
This might have something to do with
Lucas's desire to have a naturalistic
documentary feel to the movie.
Something he often argued about with Gil
Taylor,
but an empire.
The helmet is as smooth as volcanic
glass and always spotlessly clean so
that it features these fat white
reflections which highlighted shape
Kirschner,
and so she seemed to understand that
visually vader increased in dramatic
weight.
The less naturalistic and more pure that
he seemed after all,
the most iconic symbols in our culture
are the ones that can be boiled down to
their basic shape and still be
instantaneously recognizable.
Episode five takes advantage of this
with the masterful use of silhouette.
It's in these moments that vader
transcends his role as a character in a
movie and becomes a symbol for something
much deeper and much more universal.
The empire strikes back,
I think is inventive with it's darth
vader imagery in a way that both of the
other films aren't as much with only 12
minutes of screen time.
The filmmakers do a lot to add to the
mystique of the character and the film
features those images of vader that have
seared themselves onto my mind.
From the very first time I watched
episode six,
return of the Jedi largely holds onto
that pristine look from empire.
It even copy some of the empire shots
exactly,
but overall Jeddah is less inspired when
it comes to Darth vader cinematography.
He often looks flat against backgrounds
and the framing and lighting isn't
nearly as compelling as Kirsch nurse
work on episode five,
Kershner was so devoted to his own
vision that he didn't shoot master
shots,
which meant that Lucas would have to
edit the scenes roughly how Kirschner
intended them.
By most accounts,
Lucas' hired Richard Markwan as a sort
of working man's director for episode
six,
somebody who could bring the film in on
time and within budget and give Lucas
enough options to construct the film in
the edit.
As a result,
episode six lacks the character work
that was a signature of [inaudible]
style,
or what jetblue does give us is that
famous final scene where Darth vader is
finally unmasked.
It's a moment that brings the archetype
down to earth.
The actual face of evil is just the face
of a broken man,
more pathetic than anything,
and then that way deeply human.
Of course,
the legacy of Darth vader is an all in
the visuals,
the writing,
the costume,
and James Earl Jones vocal performance
contribute hugely to the characters,
continued faint,
even his breathing is iconic,
but film is a visual medium and when all
these things are wrapped in the right
image,
the effects can be mythic.
What's amazing is that Lucas Kirschner
achieved this in just a handful of
minutes and the impact for itself.
Hey everybody,
thank you so much for watching.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a super easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from that makes that process super
simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy whenever you want it to be.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks again for watching.
I'll see you guys next time.